that's the way to eat some pasta today
we are embarking on a very important
journey of ranking many pasta shapes
mangia with fact let's let's eat an
Italian no okay so these obviously
aren't every single pasta shape but we
have a very wide spectrum growing up I
was a very picky eater one of the only
consistent meals that I would eat was
pasta with butter and Parmesan cheese
like you I was known amongst all family
and friends to only eat buttered pasta
with Parmesan so we were pasta Queens as
good pasta Queens which is your favorite
pasta shape
my favorite is rigatoni it's got a nice
heft to it oh that's really well thought
out I just like the facility because it
reminded me of my hair here are the
criteria on which we are judging these
pasta is texture okay how much joy does
it bring you fair fair and finally how
well does it hold a sauce now we've done
our research we understand that
different shaped pastas go best with
different sauces and so we have
categorized these into red sauce pesto
and olive oil with salt and pepper and
we will be eating accordingly
I love let's go on down the line
starting with wheels wheels
I haven't eaten these in a very long
time is there an actual Italian name for
this pasta or is it just wheels put it
here I'll imposter so much this one I
feel like just kind of disintegrates in
your mouth it's structural integrity is
low I thought I'd like that more you
know the sauce is getting trapped very
well in between the spokes like the
wheel so I can understand why they would
go together
yeah this baby holds a lot of sauce and
that sauce is so good Oh mm-hmm
we're at black sand texture it makes up
for in sauciness yes and saltiness is a
wah yeah yeah it does not sponge over me
if it's a yes or a No
I'm leaning no sorry wheels sigh
rigatoni I love this one I rarely eat
rigatoni so I'm excited to like dive
into your world a little bit yeah I
think that this is a virtually perfect
pasta shape I like that you can slide it
onto a fork bro I love it mm-hmm feels
like a whole meal Debra
see look yeah she's just like a big
envelope for a saucing the ridges hold
the sauce on the outside the fact that
it's a tube holds the sauce on the
inside
that rings higher on my scale and I
thought it would good don't you texture
8.9 joy yes yes how well does it hold
the sauce very well my texture ranking
is a thick sparks joy for sure and holds
a sauce decently well so an all-around
good pasta all blah round nuts up we've
got spaghetti I might take a a nude with
my fingers okay
[Music]
satisfying it's a gift that keeps on
giving
hey hey hey cuz you put the beginning in
your mouth and then you gotta keep
putting more in your mouth this is also
like the classic pasta of romance
because of lady in the [ __ ]
[Music]
what would that panache Oh a little
flick of the wrist
almost like salt bay mm-hmm basic
flavorful textures and yeah textures a
yeah sparks joy for sure duckface joy
okay okay from prior experience we know
it holds Foss very well so way to go
spaghetti fusilli Izumi my favorite one
because it reminds me of the hair I had
before I cut it perfect so many ridges
good texture love a good Ridge
it holds the sauce very well texture
wise I give it a I give it a pull up it
sparks joy for sure yes down on I am
sauciness it's a sausage it's very like
melody I think we can leave it at that
great love it it's better Jeanne
basically just flat spaghetti that's a
good serving you ready love this is your
quarterback it's reliable it's gonna go
all the way home into the end zone field
goal pasta this is a long slippery pasta
so I imagine it doesn't hold a sauce
very well you know it's just like home
oh no this is getting some points doctor
for clumpiness
we are so delicate doesn't really spark
joy for me I think it does but I'm
pretty much gonna say everything sparks
joy does its pasta I give it oh yeah I
give it a huh my childhood favorite
farfalle the bowtie are you getting
tired of eating pasta at this point oh
yeah are you okay man I feel like I need
a bigger unit tell me more about that it
still brings me just as much joy as it
did in my childhood I enjoy the denser
middle section and then the delicate
crimped ending sauce Meowth daddy I
don't think that this hold sauce very
well oh I'm Europeans Ron texture-wise
for me it's a solid six it's a way to go
it brings me joy how well does a hold of
sauce well a nope no angel hair I love
angel hair it's very aptly named hmm I
like that because it's so thin you get a
lot in one bite and then you feel like
all of the little strings where the
texture is really nice legs I know
champagne it's like you've got the
liquid and then you've got the googlebot
it's a pasta it's the champagne of pasta
it's delicious angel hair I didn't think
was going to be a contender today and
there were probably a lot of angel hair
haters out there I'm just here to tell
you that angel hair is great texture is
wild and wonderful texture is Prosecco
brings me joy how are y'all brings me
more food sauce just fine
penne this one is like olives and the
stuff that used to put olives on all my
fingers own item to think of penny is
like completely middle of the road
it's kind of like the basic [ __ ] pasta
it's fine I will say that it does hold
sauce very well mm-hmm that's all up in
their texture is a 12 I just kill a 10 1
Ms I'm gonna say the texture is like a
Toyota Camry perfectly fine color does
the spark joy no no next up the shell I
love a good shell I think this one does
spark joy for me I'm full of joy
I like good and pasta whoo yeah baby
this is a good pasta to sauce ratio
because it's about even texture I'd give
it a very good I would give it going on
like a better-than-average vacation does
a spark joy for me hell yeah
for me it does yeah I would say if
sparks joy and then does it hold a sauce
yes yes finally the elbow this elbow
macaroni to me that's a garbage pasta
shame shots fired
yeah Alba macaroni is never good yeah
structural integrity could probably be
better here come that like eing handle
laughs no I like it got a little wet for
me I like it
and they even you know I already know
this one doesn't spark joy for me it's a
little mushy
yeah it's Vivi machine I am excite I
like these elbows you know my new
favorite part of the body is elbow no
this is not a pasta to me this is a
noodle that wants to be a pasta my god
yeah it's aggressive
all right final ranking y'all final
ranking elbow macaroni would be my least
favorite I'm gonna tie that with wheels
I would say penny
sorry little tubes fourth worst now I'll
say fettuccine you would say bowtie I
don't think that phacelia will tie them
then I would put bowtie and I would put
spaghetti we love a tie a bowtie
third best pasta shells yeah I agreed
Jumbo shells or tiny shells you are
getting what you pay for it I'm gonna
say we should put angel hair second I
feel like the heft of a rigatoni there's
a perfect processor I didn't come into
this room expecting to feel this way so
I'm just I'm working that out with
myself I told you you're gonna trust me
the hair of angels and then some big ol
tubes rigatoni
yeah burger Tony is the best posture
shake at the end of the day pasta is all
about joy and carbs there's really no
wrong answer yeah pasta to me it's about
getting a huge hunk in your mouth and
just going to town
pasta pasta
[Music]